hey l v in this [__] check me out on
the bootleg Kev podcast we G to rent it
up on the game oh hey about to get into
a new interview want to shout out to our
sponsor Imperial they're giving you a
free that's right free 2 G top shelf
pre-roll with the glass tip that's right
delivered right to your door all right
it's free all you got to do is pay
shipping use the promo code bootleg at
Imperial
extraction. comom there's a 1.5 G of
premium flour plus a half a gram of thca
diamonds loaded up in this thing and
guess what you could get one for free
with the promo code bootleg go to
Imperial extraction. comom it's free you
just pay shipping let's get into the
interview yo ble Kev podcast special
guest here Lil V is here welcome oh
little V in this [__] what's up man
what's the deal bro well I was just
having this conversation with our buddy
uh I don't know if you know you know
Gabe C he's blast DJ used to be a Power
106 he's DJ's on serus I might have
heard of him uh but we're talking about
like La rap right let's say Southern
California hip-hop if you will MH and uh
it's been a drought the only thing in
the last year that's popped is
you and 310 baby yeah 310 baby shout out
to him and it's uh it's is it's it's I
mean You' you've kind of like figured
out this uh
this formula of yours I want to get into
it but first of all before we do that
like give me kind of some of your
background what part of C you from um
how long you been rapping give me give
me the whole rundown for sure [__] I'm
from South Central LA feel me I'm 28 uh
I've been moving around all throughout
la like my whole life like since I was a
baby I don't know if you familiar with
all the streets but I grew up on third
Aven Exposition okay moved from there to
like 48th and second out 54th and third
out just like all you were moving around
moving around like every three or four
years of my whole life I was moving but
just all throughout La I went to Tom
Bradley Elementary I went to Palms
Middle School in uh cover City and then
I graduated high school at dorsy high
school oh okay yeah that's what's up
yeah and so how what about like cuz I
barely maybe heard of you maybe about a
year ago now a year MH I think him Beezy
came up here he was supposed to come up
here but his manager was here and he was
I think he managed you too or he did
yeah he did Y and uh he was like yo Lil
V and I was like I keep hearing that and
you were getting booked in Arizona like
little spots who the [__] is this guy on
me and I'm not I mean I I'm on Tik Tok
like you go to my Tik Tok page and check
out my content but I'm not on Tik Tok
like that yeah I'm not swiping and oh
what's this song that's you know but you
going crazy on Tik Tok and [__] um but
how long like what's the music Journey
like for you like man I really I've been
doing music since 2017 for real but I
didn't take it serious till 2020 that's
when I really put my foot on the gas and
started getting on around the city I had
this song called gangsters and ratchets
and I had put like four artists on it
like ashbash Chef boy uh killer F from
Fanatics then I got RI on it shout out
to so I can't yeah shout out RCI I came
off the rip trying to like be on some
like Unity you know unite bring
everybody together and I made like a
banger and for the whole first minute of
the song is just me gassing probably
like I think like 32 bars or something
and then everybody else got like a 16
and that's what got me buzzing in the
city for real in 2020 and
then I didn't blow up for real for real
until whopp it came out right that's
what really changed everything for me
changed my life but that was just a year
ago that wasn't long ago n that was just
a year ago before that I was still
working 9 to5 what was your last 9 to
five last 9 to five uh stizzy I worked
at in stizzy Warehouse the dispensary at
the warehouse stuff oh shout out to
steezy even though they don't sponsor us
they reached out once right yeah that
was just like a little over a year ago
probably like so you were like just like
helping with the like the packing and
packaging everything putting the labels
on [__] like that that was my last job
on me just in 2022 like at the end
that's fire do you still get like stizzy
like if you need some no n I don't
really go there like that I don't really
smoke like that for real oh you're not a
big smoker nah I just stopped drinking
too oh good for you yeah for the new
year what inspired you to stop drinking
uh just I'll be going too crazy yeah I'm
a shot a clock every 5 minutes type of
[__] you feel me so and you're in the
club lot cuz you get booked in all the
clubs no I've been booked all year so
what was your uh like drink of choice
tequila I'm assuming yeah for sure casam
Migo's rep of course everybody off a
Kasa always I just wonder when the
tequila era is going to end I don't
think it's ever going in because it went
from like the Henny era sarak had a run
uh us white boys had Fireball for a
little bit uh yeah I never I never even
tasted that Fireballs fire what I was
off that that [__] for like eight years
of my life that [__] crazy um but but
it's it's 100% the pandemic created the
tequila wave I think so oh yeah cuz
everybody was getting the Ed and then
they were able to go get the the 194 the
1942 and the [__]
classa and then KAS Amigos just blew the
[__] up in the pandemic so now everyone
drinks tequila which is it probably the
best liquor healthwise you could drink
yeah I mean it's all [__] it's
liquor but if if you had to pick one
definitely going to be that's what's up
uh you have F cancer on your face what
inspired that uh I lost my dad to cancer
in 2016 oh damn what kind of cancer uh
pancreatic and then it wind up spread
into his liver like later that's a tough
that's tough man yeah but that's what
pretty much inspired me to even rap for
real like tell my story and [__] like
that it's dope too because you know when
we think of like LA Hip Hop a lot of
people who don't live here or who just
kind of perceive whatever LA Hip Hop or
the scene is like here I feel like
sometimes they think of negativity first
because of some of the politics some of
the gang stuff that happens here but
like right you know I think back to like
rewind to like
2011 12 even 2010 the party music that
was getting made you know like YG even
before that with the jerk movement and
like you know what I'm saying so it's
dope to see like like the stuff we're
talking about
like uh is is fun it's party music right
you know what I mean like no definitely
that uh that wave like those years that
you just mentioned that all in inspired
my whole career like you see the samples
I'll be doing be like a lot of songs
from back then that's when I was like in
high school and going to little clubs
and [__] you feel me hearing YG Joe
Moses tit Allis sign all those I'm just
I'm trying to bring back that type of
energy just like it's missing feel me it
definitely missing it's missing in
general in music yeah but sure for sure
especially out here though like no
especially here but just in general like
I'm thinking like damn like like the
club records that I could play that are
current that are between like 95 bpms
and like a 110 there it's just it's
really your [__] and 310 baby that's
current there's nothing else that's true
there's nothing else I don't even [__]
with under like like 110 no more I'm my
[__] be like 112 and up no your shit's
your shit's up there yeah it's crazy
it's I got a beat match high for sure um
so oh me I'm curious when I heard your
stuff I was like there's no way any of
these samples are
cleared they are now they are now yeah
they they for sure are now but they
worked for a while yeah N Hell No cuz I
was like damn yeah this
motherfucker's he's just
running yeah you feel me I was just I
didn't really know much about the
business part of uh the music industry
when I was coming up I was just young
hungry and um like I said that era 2011
2012 YG and and all that I was like in
love with that that era of music so I
just wanted to like put my own taste on
those beats so when I was coming up you
know I didn't know nothing about
clearance samples or any of that I was
just I hear a remix I turn that
[__] on and gas up and then once
I started catching some steam and I'm
like okay I got to learn the business
side right so that's when I started
getting lawyers you feel me and [__]
like that whyn't it say like did anybody
anybody hit you like does tiger reach
out to you and be like hey bro this is
cool but like I'mma need my bag taer
definitely reached out to me not on know
I'mma need my bag [__] it was more on
some let me help on remix type [__] okay
okay okay I don't know what happened
[__] well that's the thing it's like
yeah get on the remix so then we can
actually clear it right on God in heaven
but I don't know like I feel like all
the artists that that's coming up right
now is getting remixes with much more
ease I don't know if you you noticed
that but like like 310 baby like boom he
got like five popping crazy ass artists
on the remix and I feel like I haven't
had that opportunity Unity to just I
think it's going to happen I think so
who I I think I think
um I think a lot of it is
like well one like Soak City Soak City
is a [__] big record it's huge huge
record and I think that you know uh
that his team is he's got a good team
around yeah for sure for sure he does
have a great team around shout out to my
guy Gentry um I don't know what your
team's like so I can't speak to your
team well I'm independent for sure I
just got a manager you feel me I
recently you just got a new manager like
cuz you told me you had your old manager
yeah I had to get rid of that situation
but I do have a new manager now but I'm
still independent like I don't have no
so is your is your stuff just straight
Dro kid yeah oh [__] yeah so how hard is
it to clear these big records after
they're already out well it just depends
on who you know for real cuz how okay
what songs all together have you sampled
so far [__] cuz it's a lot as far all
right so as far as like after I got on
[__] it eat it up up that's another my
sample I sample lean back well you know
the song is yeah Rack City you feel me
uh lean back up I love to me the
toughest was the toughest is the
toughest one to clear Usher yes it has
to be yeah that was the toughest one we
got it all taken care of now but that
was definitely that had to be tough cuz
that's a that's a mega hit right there
that's one of the biggest songs ever on
me and that's that's one that I was like
like I didn't touch it like d near I
think it was like four years until until
my career that I I wanted to do it I'm
like damn I want to do yeah but I'm like
that's too big of a hit let me let me
Chill on that one and then as soon as I
did it w it took off damn on me it's
like damn it be like that though like
songs that I that I want to do like Rack
City I I wanted to do that beat years
ago but I'm like let me just hold on to
it I got to do something special so do
you have a producer that knows how to
speed up the [__] the way you like it
hell yeah I'm Lo in with my producers
shout out L great uh scum Uno and then
my engineer here also producer his name
marf he make a lot of money I about to
say for what you do an engineer really
can just do it yeah just speed it up in
Pro Tools my engineer all right so chop
it the right way new drums under it all
the beats that I got that y'all hearing
it don't sound like that when a producer
send it to me it sound like some whole
other [__] engineer got to put his hands
on it hell yeah I'll tell which is
producing yeah for sure definitely hey
we got to stop the interview to tell you
about our good folks want to give a
shout out to odd Sox that's right baby
go to Odd Socks official.com they just
celebrated 10 years 10 years of odd Sox
that's right use the promo code bootleg
right now you'll get 20% off all right
look they got all the socks they're the
most comfortable socks in the world
though i' actually like to point out
that that's a fact uh well it's also
factually my opinion but I am telling
you you won't find a more comfortable
sock than Odd Socks now the real key is
guys the odd Sox Basics these right
here these are the only socks on my feet
if you saw me um on NBA young boys couch
with some wet dusty ass snow ridden sock
it was a white odd Soxs
basic the most comfortable sock in the
world they got all the licenses they got
[__] Crush they got Baja Blast Beav
and Butthead Hot Cheetos Modello I mean
uh Scarface we can go on and on and on
they got the underwear they got it all
look if you like A1 steak sauce they got
a pair of draws for that ass go to oock
official.com right now use the promo
code bootleg save 20% off a checkout
thank me later also want to give a big
shout out to the good folks of King pom
that's right baby if y'all don't know
about King pom let me tell you about
King pom bro first of all we're talking
about straight raw organic goodness hand
me a box Cyrus hand me a box give me a
box oh my goodness look what's dope
about King pom is no tobacco straight
organic natural Leaf all right oh we got
more oh we got more oh these are the
dragon fruit King sizes Jesus Christ how
much King P my [__] God just King
Palms listen that's all we smoke out of
right and they got the turpine infused
tips with that flavor listen bro the
flavor let me just show you what that
looks like like this right here it's
some of that blue
grape you know you light that up you
maybe put put some of your favorite
premium uh whatever you want in there
you know you light it up you got the tip
you squeeze that bad boy you're getting
hit with a rush of flavor um and right
now 50% off when you go to King pom.com
and use the promo code bootleg they got
Grinders they got uh what else do they
got they got goddamn ashtrays they got
all the all the King Palm leaves in the
world my favorite though right now I do
love the sugar Shan the sugar Shan honey
orange is fire all right 7-Eleven you
can go get King palom at 711 you go to
your local lior liquor store and load up
on King palom it's a clean way to smoke
it's a great way to smoke it's a natural
way to smoke tobacco free straight
leafing it um I will never smoke out of
anything but a king pom for the rest of
my life all right so shout out to King
pom go to king pom.com one more time
promo code bootleg save 50% off at
checkout half half off what are we
talking about let's get back to the
interview yeah it's interesting cuz I I
like I like it cuz what you're doing
is it is it's just the new T it's fun
you know what I'm saying right
and is there is is have you decid have
you have you [__] around with doing
anything not that isn't sample based
yeah I'm about to I'm about to turn in
my album actually today is how much of
it is samples how much of it is it uh
cuz you're kind of known for that only
samples are the songs that y'all heard
already oh nice yeah so it's like same
BPM range though is like that your
that's your bag I'm versatile I got a
whole different range that people don't
even know about that's why I haven't
been doing any interviews cuz I really
been wanting people to just hear a
different side of me first you feel me
right now everybody think I'm just a
club guy I got all these type of turnup
bangers which I do but I got a whole
another side to me so now that I'm about
to put this project out I'm open to like
doing interviews you know just so people
can get a different side me first well
you you obviously you alluded to being
fully independent like that can't be uh
everyone's got to be on your line though
I mean maybe not everybody but a lot of
people are banging your line for sure
for sure since the beginning so what has
been the reason why you haven't tried to
go with label yet I feel like I haven't
reached my full potential yet well yeah
because you're whatever deal you sign
right now they're going to [__] you in
some Capac I mean I don't want to use
the word [__] you but for sure but but
but they they they might have the
leverage you could you could put this
album out build up a lot more leverage
and then come back to the table and get
a much better deal probably right that's
my plan yeah definitely that's crazy man
it's wild too cuz man I feel like uh you
know there's been um so many dope La
artists
that I'm going to tell you this be
careful cuz sometimes I've I've seen
this happened
where people will overthink
themselves out of being bigger because
they want to stay independent a little
longer ah I see what you're saying I've
seen this happen and I I mean some of
the bigger La names
ever had a really big record I'm not
talking about recently I'm talking about
let's say the last 10 or 12 years I had
opportunities to take deals and like
maybe Elevate things to another level
and we're like nah not yet so just be
careful with that you know right cuz if
because you never know if the album
comes out and it doesn't do what you
hope it does
right then it can hurt you with talks
well I'm nobody notice but I'm putting
my album out through a Distribution
Company oh you're doing Dro yeah Empire
no create oh create shout out to create
cate's doing their thing yeah yeah yeah
that's a good see creates a you want a
partner like that you know what I'm
saying somebody who's who give you some
label services but not [__] exactly
yes hell yeah that's the way to go right
there for sure yeah that's smart so I'm
excited to hear what you guys so is
there any remixes being worked on uh
yeah I got a lot of uh I got a lot of
remixes on the way
I'm just I just been saving everything
for real yeah yeah just getting ready
like for the album have you had like
like a good experience with some of the
ogs on the LA side of hip-hop in terms
cuz you there's no way everyone's in the
club here they all are at [__] uh you
know the clubs they're all they're all
at dragonfly they're all at Kingpin
Mondays they're all here in your records
so they know your
[__] has it been a a positive experience
with any of these guys
anybody reached out like you said hey I
don't know how I you know like you
mentioned earlier like 31 babies got
five of these he got mustard blue bucks
[__] blue face all on the remix like
right honestly I feel like uh I've been
having good and bad
experiences um I'll say more bad than
good for sure like a lot of people reach
out to me I'm not going to throw no
names out there but [__] will reach
out and be like I'll [__] with what you
doing I'll [__] with movement let's do
something and that's be like all right
come on yeah let's come on hey I'm in
the studio tonight I'm at the studio
right now what you trying to do I'll
never hear from him again wow ever and
it just kind of make me feel like damn
like is it because I'm only doing
remixes maybe they don't maybe they
don't think the record will get cleared
maybe that might be it maybe but I got
that side handled though well now they
know yeah we'll see maybe they'll [__]
with for me now I nah I mean either way
though that's that's that's disingenuine
though like don't reach out to me if
like we can't go get in and cut some
[__] bro I'm really BR I'm really like
from the slum like I'm from La you feel
me so to get hit up by these people that
I looked up to it's a big deal it's a
big deal to me like I don't I don't act
Hollywood about it or nothing right I'll
take that [__] to heart when I first uh
started blowing up off of whopp it and
tiger DM me I cried I'm not going livee
wow I cried cuz that was my first not
cuz it was Tiger it was just like n but
that's a that was my first time getting
uh getting notoriety from somebody big
and that reaffirms that you're on the
right path exactly I'm talking about
this at the very beginning in January W
it blew up in December I look at my
phone I wake up from a nap with my son I
look up tiger who It remix I'm like what
the [__] I show my mom I started
screaming I couldn't believe it that's
so fire cuz that's a moment that could
change somebody life you feel me no cuz
I mean even if nothing comes from that
it's like well [__] if Tiger saw it and
[__] with it that means I'm on the
right path exactly I'm sure you've had
other DMs like that yeah it been a
shitload of them but I'm saying that
that first one like that's what really
got me emotional for real but I'm just
saying like throughout this process and
this path that I've been on I've run
into a lot of situations like that like
people will tap in with me and speak
positive and then I'll never hear from
them what about the guys who you do hear
from who you have had positive
experiences with who are they man shout
out Ty doign that's like my he's the
best yeah I [__] love Ty doign I owe
him everything he's actually one of the
more like genuine good human beings I've
known him since
2010 11 yeah and uh I mean he just
invited me out to Vegas and uh I was
hanging out with him and his his
daughter and we were chilling with Kanye
all night he literally was like man come
out shout out Kanye and and
um I was like the coolest night of my
life to be honest I'm like in a room
with like I mean you know I'm there with
Tai right but I'm Kanye's there and
[__] Legends Tiger's there and Y G's
there and yeah little Derk was there uh
kid cuy was there oh this the album [__]
they did this was in a [__] at the at
the Four Seasons in Vegas and Kanye
Suite oh [__] it was they were finishing
the album and then it turned into like a
party and then somehow India Love
started cutting vocals it was so Rand
bro it was and I'm shroomed the [__]
out I'm like this I can't [__] with the
strs bro I was like this [__] is crazy
all right so you say Ty we know Tai is
the greatest shout out to Ty yeah shout
out to Ty and also one of the most
talented human beings to ever do
anything he's a [__] alien legend yes
uh Ty YG for sure definitely [__] with
each other uh whiz whiz is great me and
whiz got a a real good relationship I
love whiz oh yeah [__] just uh a lot of
the up and cominging like La artists
that was on before me like the one te JS
at a ches yeah those Jeezy like just I
love ozy man yeah I [__] with him yeah
me oez going to have a long career man
cuz he's a good dude man definitely me
and X4 got a real good relationship he's
great too I I I free him free x4 I me
cuz we we did a uh interview and I
didn't know what to expect yeah and he
was like the coolest [__] me you
got the real good sign out of he was so
funny and then like he saw I went uh he
saw went hog hunting uh in Texas with
that Mexican OT he DM me he's like we
got to go do
this I was like bro let's go he's like
no for real let's do it I like I'm down
let's go hunting like yeah free x4 free
him man he's he's got he's going to have
a if he can get his [__] together he
he's got a bright future most definitely
hell yeah damn yeah you know I want to
hear you want a song blue face though oh
yeah oh we got a song together do you I
haven't heard it it's s a cut though
nobody know about it I want to hear that
that's on the way blue faces again cool
dude a lot of people say what y'all want
about blueface he's mastered he run the
internet though he has mastered the
internet man it's crazy I it's really
like since
69 no one has figured out the internet
better than him I think so yeah in terms
of just like I'm not talking about
anything
and how you feel about 69ine when he was
hot he had the internet Master internet
on Smash 247 he bro he broke man I
interviewed his baby mama and him 6
months ago and I thought it was a joke
yeah and his lightweight was a joke yeah
it was like baby mama music and she put
out the Stewie song and yeah I told her
to her face her music sucked and
she and she got a deal with Columbia
Records oh God in heaven bro I don't
think who else can do that BL face I
don't think they they even believed it
was going to be on that level like when
they first started around but the Barbie
record is hot that [__]
crazy and it's like who else could do
that bro that's insane when you this is
his son's this his kid's mom and he was
like you know what I'mma show y'all it
ain't about her it's about me and I'mma
put her on right it's
crazy to Blue Man hey we got to stop the
interview real quick man shout out to
our family at my bookie NFL season is
winding down you still got some regular
season uh games you can get in on of
course the college bowl games are coming
up so much money to get plus the cash
priz is going down in their week
Blackjack tournaments at
mybookie.ag and uh this is what's going
on right uh my bookie is crazy cuz
they're doing this if you sign up right
now at my bookie use the promo code
bootleg all right claim your deposit
match redeemable up to $1,000 that's
right they're going to match your first
deposit up to
$1,000 using the promo code bootleg
claim your bonus NFL college bowl game
so much going on in terms of what you're
trying to get down with if you want to
gamble if you want to bet all right they
got Blackjack they got roulette they got
it all uh and of course the best odds
anywhere online when it comes to your
sports betting needs so one more time
sign up right now with that promo code
bootleg um and I'm going to tell
everybody this uh you're going to get
your first deposit match up to
$1,000 I'mma put my money I'm feeling
good about the 49ers future BET right
now slam the ners to win the Super Bowl
I think they're taking that whole [__]
bet anytime anywhere with my bookie hey
um thank you for watching also shout out
to King pom geez I'm just swimming in
King pom but we got a shout out to our
good Folks at bluechew that's right
bluechew.com man New Year time to get
that uh that dick of yours in order
maybe you're dealing with the rectile
dysfunction stress at work maybe you're
married 30 years into the marriage it's
a little hard to get it up for wifey
over there but you want to you know
smash her uh down take her to pound town
real quick for the anniversary what I
suggest you do is [__] with some
bluechew that's right bluechew what is
it does it work first of all of course
it works yes it does work I've used it
it's great uh with that being said blue
Chu it is the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Calis all right trust me oh
they hit all right in a nice chewable
form yeah and it gets delivered straight
to your doorstep discret packaging you
don't got to worry about going to a
doctor's appointment sitting in an
office and speaking with some stranger
about the issues with your Johnson it's
all online all online if you're asking
what I don't know man this sounds like I
don't know I don't you know how much is
it what do we got to do to get it look
it's free that's right free you can get
your first month of bluechew for free
right now all right your dick deserves
it whoever's taking your dick deserves
it let's be honest all right so go to
blu.com use the promo code bootleg right
now and guess what your first month will
be delivered for free all you got to do
is pay $5 shipping blu.com promo code
bootleg get your first month for free
delivered right to your doorstep and
thank me later all right let's get back
to the interview um hell yeah for your
album is cuz cuz you're also like I feel
like you do make party music but like
you could tell in these records that you
could really rap for real I'm definitely
oh we're going to get a lot of bars on
this uh project oh hell yeah I'm
spilling my heart out on this
[__] for real that's dope man
cuz I do feel like like even though
these are party records I could hear it
oh this F is snap yeah you hear it you
hear the C it
Cadence is there crazy any features on
the album oh definitely blue face crazy
on N blue face not on it but I got some
I got some big features though I'm not
going to say right now I'm tur it in
today but I got some big like Global
like Snoop Dog N I got you said Global
damn near on that level though damn near
yeah whiz maybe it's definitely whiz
maybe that's Global on that level never
know it's
whiz whiz on the album um I'm dead he
didn't say no uh when's the album coming
out uh I'm pushing for later this month
but I'm I'm going to get the release
date and everything today what is your
favorite cuz you've been getting booked
at these clubs and I don't want you to
run into the same problem I've seen guys
I'll even say it ad who's my brother so
he knows I can I could speak about ad
like this when ad was out he did so many
clubs m
that I feel like it kind of burnt his
brand out a
little I don't think you're doing that
yet yeah but is that something you're
aware of most definitely I just had this
conversation with one of my homies he
like I need to become more exclusive cuz
since I just blew up last year only been
a year that's how I've been getting
money since I'm in yeah that's how
you're supporting yourself cuz you're
not getting cuz also you I mean the
streams ain't paying like that [__] n
the streams paying but but but you for
example if you if you go and pick up a
five bands from a club that's like a 1.1
million streams on Spotify cuz streams
is 30 okay I see what you mean streams
$3800 for a million streams on Spotify
you know what I'm saying so like you
could go like I always look at [__] like
streaming numbers like all right well if
you can go do this party and get $3
million or 3 million streams worth of
money real quick what the [__] right but
you also like you said like you got to
be careful cuz like I said with ad when
ad had juice that [__] was
everywhere God I remember that he lived
in the club hell yeah and I don't know
if it hurt him or I mean him and I have
talked about it so I think I think it
hurt him a little though yeah it can't
hurt you I just started turning down
bookings like for real like maybe like
in the last three or four months and I
mean look to be fair the LA club scene
isn't what it was before the pandemic
what trust me I know r&p to Playhouse
yeah um but it's still a thing but it's
not like what it was yeah it's not but
like you could still go hit Scottdale
and I mean Arizona is my spot yeah yeah
you get booked in Arizona I'm out there
like I've been out there like more than
any it's pretty crazy yeah I remember we
were talking like early on when you were
bubblin M you know my club group chat
cuz I own a club out there yeah and uh
my boy was like yo we could do a little
V and somebody replied they're like I
saw this [__] at a brunch a CL a
hook out all in the same weekend when I
go to Arizona I'll run it up I'll be
everywhere yeah Brunch House 11-11
pretty pleased
Airbnb parties you don't even yeah he's
EAS A vibe man over for sure uh anything
else you're working on or anything else
you want to talk about man uh [__] I'm
working on my clothing line my f cancer
clothing line yeah I'm trying to set up
something with my album where uh
percentage of the proceeds that I make
could go towards like a cancer uh
organization make sure it's like one
that like I feel like some of the bigger
ones are so much bureaucracy wrapped up
in like where the money goes like it's a
lot yeah you always got to worry about
that but it's coming from a genuine
place for me no that's amazing feel me
so yeah uh yeah my clothing line that
should be out like around when my album
come out trying to set up everything uh
[__] just be ready for my album it's
going to be 16 songs 12 of them going to
be brand new a lot of hot features a lot
of styles that y'all never heard from me
before uh [__] not to end the interview
on a a somber note but obviously the you
know you losing your dad at cancer is a
big deal to you big deal to anybody for
you
what would be some advice if someone
lost a parent um what would be the
advice you would give to them how to
cope how to mourn how to get through it
how to get on the other side of it you
know uh well first let me explain to you
how it even happened first so pretty
much uh 2016 I was working at FedEx used
to work at the warehouse at
LAX and um you know when he first got
diagnosed with it that [__] hurt you
feel me but he was taking all the
precautions to get rid of it like
everything I'm talking about to a t Cho
everything wake up at this time take
this you feel me coffee enemas salads
like everything everything so um he got
rid of it uh he got rid of the
pancreatic cancer and he got rid of it
for about two months then he came to my
house one day he was like uh came back
to his liver though so I'm like damn
here this go again so after that
happened uh I'm working I'm working you
know he's still doing his [__] he C my
mom came to my job at FedEx my mom don't
go
nowhere like she literally don't leave
the house so when my manager like my mom
here I'm like what the [__] I'll rush to
the front she like oh they gave him two
months I'm like wow damn yeah that [__]
hit different I left the job you feel me
crying all type of [__] and then uh
after that day it was about two weeks
was about two weeks uh my stepmom wind
up calling me from the hospital she like
yeah it's that time so I Rush up there
when I got there he taken like like a
breath like every 45 seconds or 30
seconds barely hanging on barely hanging
on so what a lot of people don't know is
I actually got to see my dad take his
last breath wow yeah like literally the
last one whole family standing over him
like trying to touch him a little bit
like make sure he stay up and once he
took that last one he was out
so that right there like seeing that was
so detrimental to me that's what sparked
like me to even do music you feel me so
me like blowing up and even being able
to sit right here with you is like like
whoa It's like a real Testament to my
journey like I can't even believe I'm
here you're lucky to have been there
with him no definitely right cuz you cuz
I I had it both ways when my so my
grandpa when he passed away I was
holding his hand oh wow yeah and I was
it was me and my cousin in the room with
him MH cuz he was in hospice and they
and they knew he was going to die so
they brought him back to my my family's
house so I was holding his hand
literally while he died yeah so I felt I
don't want to say I felt good about it
but I felt like at peace with it yeah
during Co my grandma died of Co in a
nursing home and they wouldn't let us be
with her because of Co so she died alone
that's [__] up that [__] [__] me up
cuz you're like damn like we wanted to
be there but this Co [__] right they
wouldn't let anybody in the nursing home
so my grandma passed away by herself we
don't know what she was thinking we
don't know nothing you know what I'm
saying rest in you're lucky to have been
with your been there for show for show I
don't take that for granted that that
moment just like that's like a real you
know that I hold that [__] right here
like n that's dope it's a part of your
mission now definitely but as far as
advice I would say
um if you Lo lost anyone you feel me for
anybody that lost someone find something
to not take your mind off of it cuz
nothing gonna take your mind off pour
the pain into something into something
that's exactly something productive for
sure something productive CU you could
pour it into something negative exactly
you know [__] 100% pour it in something
positive you feel me find something if
it's going to the gym whatever you feel
me find something that's going to fuel
you and like make you put on for your
person you lost well you've done a good
job man appreciate you salute on the
success um I look forward to hearing the
album and you got a name for the
album kingar ratchet kingar ratchet yeah
that's what we've been missing in La
y'all yeah back to the ratchet [__] we
going to stamp that
yeah you're going to make Joe Moses and
YG and everybody proud I got a oh hell
yeah and I I'll be doing shows with Joe
Moses and all that we got a show on on
March 4th n Joe's the greatest he's such
a nice guy out and he like a real OG and
he got a hot record right
now he's got crazy as [__] Joe's good
for like every three or four years just
a joint bounce out with something crazy
for sure shout out to Joe that remix on
the way too there it oh [__] there it is
man l v I appreciate you pulling up
brother yes sir appreciate you for
having me can we show some love to our
family at harden man shout out to harden
man look if you're in Vegas you got to
pull up you got to say take me to harden
right now I need to go to harden they're
going to take you they're going to get
you situated hardine Las Vegas the best
cannabis uh dispensary I've ever walked
into in my life the most craziest
selection of Premium cannabis in the
entire world I mean that place smells
like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Hardin Las Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
vegas.com and when you're in Vegas make
sure you pull up to harden baby